wie monaten drehen weiß ja von mir was
ihm nie verschlossen moorweg wayne iskra
diesmal beim schlagerfestival
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und der ort ich muss so in das innere
des asyl zentrum bbi bahnhof in krankt
und schweiz 3
das ist cool hier schriftlich dass die
wüste bis wir sicher sind über läuft das
haben sie hier machen das sicher wenig
später alles nehmen was die buch ist das
ist über den fristen beginnen zu laufen
das ist vor knapp 3 auf sie ich bin mit
den alltag von asylsuchenden getaucht
kochen putzen und war
[Musik]
immer wieder hat fragt was ist mensch
geworden ich wohne keine gelernten ist
das apa oli dirr so vermisst
[Musik]
jetzt briefe sie im neue die heimat
ihrer familie und das wird sie
vermutlich auch ein schwede auch smc
maxi ist hin wo zürich geschafft hat
mehr handys vorjahr nur französisch
können unterhalt inzwischen sind gut
deutsch und hat das klare ziel und alina
sie und ihre familie aus afghanistan
als sie sieht neue schweiz aber iris
hopff durch erzählte zwischenzeit
abgelegt ich habe gemerkt kopftuch und
schließlich mit kompagnon de samsung um
ihren frust sich er hat das geschafft
wofür wir sie bewerben nur durch
[Musik]
entrissen ihm asyl zentrum ihres lebens
und was indirekt räumen wäre frau conny
no mona mittendrin abdeckt
kurz vor der 7 in triberg im kanton
schwyz ist die high noon foto wendy
holdener neuerdings auf der familie asyl
[Musik]
ich werde mit offenen armen empfangen
und mit einer übrigens marke bifi alles
selber machen von der mutter halime was
ist für dich einfach soll ich hoch oder
runter hochdeutsch dass ich super
es ist schön euch hier zu sehen sms sind
glücklich dass sie noch 8 minute im
durchgangszentrum hand in den eigenen
boni kritisierte sich nutzer einfach
immer suchen wir zu erteilt und habt ihr
unteriberg gekannt vorher wurde
millionenstadt kabul
triberg ist evelyn und ganz lieb sie
halima ich schwanger flüchtet und
geburtig spitals einsiedeln geboren
wurde im durchgangszentrum halimeter
halima als babysitter reagiert
mallorca und unterstützung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sport da hat mir auch semi sogar teams
nachgeladen der mohammad ist auf gar
nicht an chinesische übersetzung sie
kalima lehrerin flüchtet ins vor dem
terror es geht typisch afghanisches asse
ries bulle pudding paul courbis ganz
einfach sie mitschuldig sein tor nur
englisch kriegt sind aber auch vintage
unterricht sowie ali bewohner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
anfang großbuchstaben
die pläne sind die zwei moskauer
schwierig sie da links im bild
[Musik]
auf feuchten putz gott muss kratz und
triberg in großer kinski
acht autos bist du für die beste
freundin
ja ja die heißt sie denn jenny
[Musik]
st
wittkowski im wald statt
[Musik]
im sommer und muskat und sie hat schoss
klaas ziehen
warum willst du lehrerin musste sich gut
integriert
ein wesentlicher teil des urmiasees
verstoße seiner familie freigeben
fragen sie noch wann es nicht verstand
und ich weiß dass so viel mit google
über 60 auch für die acht das wirklich
wissen was muss ein schwerer schlag
ich war extrem voll gemacht mit einer
politik also frage stellten wie es gibt
sie doch blieben unter dem eindruck dass
das weiß man ja nie auf muskel und ihre
familie hinter status es das heißt ihr
asylgesuch abgelehnt trotzdem ganz
beiläufig bliebe der rückkehr sich
zurzeit nicht zumutbar ihre situation
wird jedes jahr neu beurteilt
dort schweiz qasimi jeden tag drei
stunden deutschunterricht
[Musik]
am morgen der mohammad am nachmittag
talina anderthalb stunden buches mit dem
dornahof dieses buch habe ich nicht
bestanden
gut das sind genau gut
jetzt seid ihr schon drei jahre in der
schweiz
du hast eigentlich schon gut deutsch
gelernt hast du manchmal ungeduldig
ich will arbeiten und ich bin von meinen
mein geld haben beschreibt ist das
schwierig größer du hast ihr habt den in
afghanistan
mein mann hatte eine gute arbeit auf
dolmetscher und du bist der lehrerin ja
das ist so schwer wir müssen von null
anfangen
ich bin und er gern am montag mein mann
arbeitet nach dem okay ja damit immer
jemand bei den kindern sein wenn der
nacht arbeiten ja ok wer einen tag waren
sie kommen
sie haben neue meister von kindern kommt
ja
verpassen die arbeit finden oder einfach
zum triberg
für sie ist klar
geschenkt wird der mut wenn man sie die
schnitzel schafe aber sie hoffe dass
ihre chancen
als wir uns kennengelernt haben da hast
du ein kopftuch getragen jetzt nicht
mehr warum ich habe gemerkt viele leute
nicht gehen ehe mit kopftuch
also wir haben reagiert auf der haupt
und ich habe gesagt wir wollen in der
schweiz besser machen ok ihr habt ihr
miteinander diskutieren
[Musik]
diskutierten oder ich sage es gesagt ja
immer anpassen
das ist möglich und jetzt merkst du dass
die leute anders reagieren ohne echtes
jetzt nun mal man mit kopftuch alle ein
bisschen schockiert deutlich ja aber
jetzt ist normal sich integrieren
calima und brasilien macht vieles dafür
dass ihre jeans noch der flug wieder als
normales leben führen und vielleicht
schweiz derzeit die heimat findet
wo und rehberg und freienbach am zürich
see lebt bh aus dem irak jetzt im
durchgangszentrum biberbrugg an ich mit
ihrer im gleichen zimmer wohnt sie hat
flüchtlingsstatus b überholt das heißt
sie kann sich die schweiz bleibe
[Musik]
ich selber gemacht gestern hast du noch
bis in die nacht
bis am abend das thema weil wir auch
gemacht jetzt in majak was machst alles
selber du und aber das ist das ist nicht
deine deine wohnung du bist nicht allein
nein fünf frauen fünf frauen ach ja du
bist eine eine wohngemeinschaft alle
zusammen kochen ja so weh es ist ein
bisschen wie in biberbrugg mit dir man
kann fast reden du bist immer am
arbeiten aber schon asylzentrum ist zur
praktischen nonstop und putze und bach
exil
[Musik]
alles und alle hätten sich krümmen
wirken fast wie eine mutter sogar für
mich
[Musik]
familie im irak oder keine familie ist
schlimm für dich allein
[Musik]
tschuldigung
entschuldigung das machst du für peter
mir als kind ein herrscher und bulgarien
der bh ihre verwandte hat flucht die
alle himmelsrichtungen verstreut
für sie ist das schwer zu music sie
[Musik]
an der situation hat sich bis heute
nicht geändert
sie ist die einzige der familie wurde
[Musik]
schwierig sagt ein wichtiger mensch
ihrem label studie cygnet erich ihren
betreuer vom sozialzentrum vater gemeint
heute habe ich einige sachen da war das
ist für sie werden ja die chance dass
ich das ist nach gesundheitsförderung
genau funktioniert
wer den eastman ist ein von der weniger
vertraute von der sapinda ihre
geschichte sie hat mir auch erzählt ihre
verwandten ihre familie für eigentlich
alle in amerikas vor allem in schweden
und sie ist die einzige die in der
schweiz ist sie ist ein flüchtling
kontingent gegner also durch uhren hause
ist die schweiz gekommen
das heißt vor ort hat hier
wahrscheinlich auch sie die unterlagen
eingereicht und ist dann ist das für
mich quasi angenommen oder akzeptiert
okay du erfüllst die fünf eigenschaften
er und wie vermutung sozialzentrum hilfe
dass es das hier einen fehler gemacht
haben also mitarbeiter konnte nur inhalt
sie haben
schweden und schweiz verwechselt das ist
unsere vermutung das müssen wir eben
nicht weil normalerweise resettlement
flüchtlinge dürfen zu eltern gehen oder
zu verwandten
und verwandte wohnen und bei ihr ist das
was komisches passiert also das ist
unsere vermutung dass sie jeden
schweizer schwelen verwechselt haben
kann gut möglich sein wenn das wirklich
so ist ich liebe fürs leben für das abba
unglaublich folge hält können wir ja
nicht ständig machen das ist ja nur im
hause wo wir keinen einfluss haben also
da kann man nicht sagen warum kann er
nicht nach schnellen leute nicht das un
hcl seit auf nachfrage sondern fehler
sich nicht möglich
wirklich dicke der entscheid habe nie so
viele sachen familie sind nur als
kriterium
es gibt es rätsel als spitzel glücklich
aber gleich kam mit dem denise er ich
noch selber als flüchtlinge cheney 24 12
jahre ohne ältere kanzlei sport da hat
der junge kurz studiert und sich
intensiv mit flüchtlings geschichte
beschäftigt jede flucht hat eine frau
die hinter sich ist ein bisschen mit
trauma verbunden
man braucht nicht so viel zahlt wie man
sich einfach nicht vorstellen kann ja
mehreren also ist geduld eigentlich
etwas zentrales einfach die geduld zu
haben bis die leute wirklich angekommen
sind richtig gut ist wirklich sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
zum können wie kaka muss erst richtig an
um ihre großen respekt vor jedem
einzelnen team weitermacht
eine hürde zum trotz
[Musik]
mini zweite sie immer noch drin ist der
gemeint brune zu erteilt wurde
lina honig direkt am gleis von der
gotthardlinie bleibt in syrien seien mit
ihrem neffen wo sie dank der flucht
warum ic kriegs druck begründete schmitt
und gerade die schuhe und ließ das wie
geht es dir jetzt ja gut sind jetzt
besonders diese jetzt ja sicher wir
erzählen ja ich will mehr neue
freundinnen und ich vielleicht im moment
bereich der uni in aleppo französisch
übersetzerin
zurzeit sind wachsen
das bild wieder zunehmen
danach gelten aber privatsphäre geht's
rumäne 4 prozent knapp prinz
quadratmeter womit tag und nacht
aufeinander
15 aber die wird mir schon wünschen dass
sie irgendwann mal wieder zurück der
familie beleg für die schwäche kämpfe
und tore schießen
da seit ihrer kinderlärm ich schon
früher mühsam wissen vielmehr über sylt
zentrum hat sie noch nie klar geht ganz
bewusst sie lieber vorwärts zu für mich
war dieses zimmer dieses vier zimmer mit
drei fremden frauen ein schock so nah
zusammen ich war drei tage da aber du
warst ein jahr und drei monate ja ja das
war sehr schwierig die leute und die
situation an die länder
du hast sehr schnell deutsch gelernt
warum hast du so viel gearbeitet oder
nein ich habe als ehrenamtlich im
altersheim gearbeitet ich habe mitte die
leuchte beim essen helfen
und wenn das wetter ist gut wir zusammen
hingegangen
ja das ist eine gute arbeit oder leider
diese arbeiten geeignet für nicht nicht
yahoo das braucht eine reine körperliche
genau das war nicht geeignet weil du
wegen deiner kinderlähmung körperlich
als auch die leute zum beispiel nicht
stützen kommen
jetzt kannst du das nicht mehr machen ja
was hast du für zähler
du möchtest arbeiten oder ich möchte
gerne eine arbeit findet in syrien hätte
status fk asyl aber vorläufig damit es
bald klappt mit dem job wird sie
unterstützt vom amt für migration in
schweiz es gibt einen sogenannten bilder
fach kurs das nennt sich jetzt da
handels diplom würde schon relativ bald
beginnen
der ist relativ streng aber sie sind
bereit für die erfreulichsten finde eine
würde deshalb wenn du keine arbeit hast
spürst du das auch dass du dann selber
das gefühl hast ich bin nichts wert
ein jobs für asylbewerber mit dem status
aufwand rhume so wichtig will wäre fixie
einstelligkeit und finanziell unabhängig
davon permanent die
aufenthaltsbewilligung beiträge
die meisten stoffe sind alle der status
f seit es ja immer wieder das wort der
studie das heißt dass wir einmal besucht
das bild gemacht mit dem staatschef
es ist ein paradox saale
status als paradox will man eine
zeitnahe integrieren andererseits aber
sie ja eigentlich nicht zu 10.000
wenigen aber wer und wo wir wählen ihn
verstehen würde ich nicht unbedingt
wahrnehmen ich weiß da ist noch nicht
wieder weg die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
natürlich relativ prix will einfach mehr
als neun prozent von deiner mit status
blieben langfristig und dauerhaft
geschützt
der satz war der hin- zahlt sich
hoffentlich bald los als sie hofft dass
ihre chance gibt
[Musik]
als asylbewerber in die schweiz buch mal
entlang schmutz um sich neues leben von
null aufbauen basis wird im asylzentrum
gleich da lernt man schweizer tugenden
wie pünktlichkeit und hochdach die
arbeiter für putzschicht wertgrund dann
werdet drei franken abzog toleranz 0 und
des reinigungs nicht gemacht ich gleich
in den kübel wenn ich es nicht tue sie
ihre den dem zusammenprall eine
unterwasserkamera kontrollierte hans der
firma wieder füllt und es tut was eine
frau dubach hat klare regeln aber sie
hat recht nicola beer gemacht ihres
credo menschen ist mesut
das macht mich als türke
ja aber wenn du denkst du warst immer
wenn sie das sehen wir weiter
ja
geklärt meistens an mit dem samsung
bucerius eritrea ist schon hier warum
bist du so lange wie alt bist du ich bin
15 jahre 17 jahren
ok und das ganz alleine du auf dem auf
dem boden was sich zukunft
und die zukunft hatte samsung vom
durchgangszentrum bieber druck heftiger
schweiz braucht eine wohngemeinschaft
direkt oder autobahn
[Musik]
samsung ist jetzt 20 und gott
er macht das integrations brückenangebot
mit praktikum die mitbewohner wege sind
gerade im deutschunterricht oder
anschafft
wie viele leute insgesamt insgesamt
sieben bis zu sieben personen
ja bist du der einzige als elektra bin
ich der einzige redet miteinander
ja das ist sehr gut
das kenne ich sehr gut oder vom bebop
schon wen haben wir das klären was
machst du sonst weißt du mitgenommen
gelernt im büro
du musst das punkte sein wird und nicht
pünktlich sein
sie ziehen geld ja eine minute zu spät
war schon weniger geld ja ja aber heute
merkst du dass das wichtig ist in der
schweiz wurde ich habe gesagt was macht
einen monitor und die somit das ist frau
spricht aber so gesagt aber jetzt habe
ich gemerkt das ist sehr wichtig man
punkte durch zu sein
ja ja ja immer wenn ich alleine und das
ist mein puls ist jetzt wieder dahin
hier lernst du ja erst noch keinen tisch
selber ja und dann hast du vier tage
schule und ein tag praktikum also
arbeiten ja jetzt momentan bei techno
leyen am mittwoch
februar frankreich macht es weitergeht
ja weil ich glaube dass lehrer bekommen
hat ist eine lehre bekommen wird schon
eine lehrstelle
war das dein traum ja das war mal ein
paar mehr als ja
[Musik]
als ein wurde wenige fans in ihre klasse
geschafft
samsung kann ab somalia machen als
automechaniker deine familie hast du
noch nie so beginnt die
internet unter wir uns nicht mit so was
denkst du was sagen sie wenn du ihnen
erzählt dass du jetzt eine lehre aus
ich glaube wir stehen das nicht wenig
frage nicht der arbeit sie genau wissen
wir stehen aber mit der lehrer
erstmal habe ich auch nicht verstanden
was ist los ist bleibt wieso machen und
zwei jahre
also du hast gedacht eigentlich brauche
einfach arbeit
okay das gibt mein vater wollte ja bist
du schon weißt du gut angekommen jetzt
in der schweiz fühlst du dich schon ein
bisschen zu hause jetzt schon viel
besser alleine und das ist mir das war
schwierig für mich aber jetzt
[Applaus]
sie ist praktikum machte samsung in der
garage freienbach da macht
hallo frau schüller dritte wagner brahms
auseinander
ein richtigen ausbildungsplatz was sich
kurz für das samsung aber gut für die
gesellschaft will integration laufe auch
überarbeitet chef der ruhe die oper wien
ja ich hatte meine gemüter der hand und
sie werden wahrscheinlich glauben sie
möglichst schnell integrieren dann
probierte norbert sky damit sie eine
beschäftigung hat
aber es ist im vorfeld als irgendwie
unterschied dass sie wo sie in den
casinos sucht das lernen der gegenüber
verstanden erlernen der jetzt da irgend
ist schwierig sie will er aber quasi die
starke zeit dafür ist reif die einzigen
betreuer oder wie ich wollte da
unterstützt und natürlich analyse
unterstützt dann muss man mir macht der
bürokraten toni womöglich und mit
umwerfen sich regel sind es auch
offiziell das sehen das bild habe er
eigentlich habe um konto und unterstützt
musste also das heißt eigentlich für das
unternehmen
es ist nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert
deine litt arbeitsgang überhaupt nicht
ein
wir setzen sie jetzt das ansammeln von
posco hat er sicher sehr gut die und
erlebt sehr schnell und frauen max
friedrich dass er interesse hat und das
mini 3 und spielt nämlich gegangen
viele wähler und eigeninitiative
bruchhausen glück
und das wünsche ich ihnen am samsung sph
der hand und der familie aus dem irak
[Musik]
auf dem weg ganz einfacher weg zum im
schweizer fussball
[Musik]
im blick die welt wo man kennt aber
eigentlich nicht so richtig für mehr
mittendrin und andere dogs einige
abonnieren der am besten bei youtube
kanal 'so bliebe mehr miteinander in
kontakt